We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Julia Barton has been thinking about what happens when we build Big, maybe because she grew up in Dallas in the Go-Go 80s.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州和全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。朱莉娅·巴顿一直在思考当我们建造“大”东西时会发生什么，也许是因为她在80年代繁荣时期的达拉斯长大。
Big football arenas, big freeways, big houses, Texans love big. Dallas built a new city hall in 1978. Designed by IMPAY. It's this huge trapezoid jutting over a wide plaza. It's kind of wedge-shaped but upside down, so the widest and largest floors on the top. When I was a kid, sometimes I'd go up to the top floor
大型足球场、大型高速公路、大型住宅，德克萨斯人热爱“大”。达拉斯在1978年建造了一座新的市政厅。由贝聿铭设计。它是一个巨大的梯形，突出在一个宽阔的广场上。它有点像楔形，但却是倒过来的，所以最宽、最大的楼层在顶部。当我还是个孩子的时候，有时我会和朋友们去顶楼
of City Hall with my friends. That's where the vending machines were. They stalked my favorite candy bar, Caramello. I am a male lover, Caramello with my family. Then we'd sit by the windows eating chocolate and looking down over the plaza. And I think, wow, this is so cool. But later in high school, Julia went to a protest down below in the plaza. And those same City hall windows were now
市政厅。那里有自动售货机。它们存放着我最喜欢的糖果棒，Caramello。我是个巧克力爱好者，和家人一起吃Caramello。然后我们会坐在窗边吃巧克力，俯瞰广场。我想，哇，这太酷了。但后来在高中时，朱莉娅去广场下面参加了一次抗议活动。而那些同样的市政厅窗户现在
hulking over us. We could see our tiny reflections in the glass. It made me feel like a nobody. And that this whole event was a waste of time. And all of the big things in my environment seemed to be saying the same thing. I'm important, you're nobody. So Julia developed a mistrust of the big building, the big project, and places where
在我们上方显得庞大无比。我们可以看到自己在玻璃中微小的倒影。这让我觉得自己是个无名小卒。而且整个活动似乎都在浪费时间。我周围所有巨大的事物似乎都在传达同样的信息。我很重要，你什么都不是。因此，朱莉娅对大型建筑、大型项目以及那些
people seem to love the glory of the grandiose. But I'm also fascinated by those kinds of places. I can't stay away from them. Case in point, Russia. Biggest country in the world makes Texans look like amateurs. Totally. The Russians are real pros in the Department of tall, towering, and humongous. And not just from the Soviet past.
人们似乎热爱宏大荣耀的地方产生了不信任感。但我也被这类地方所吸引。我无法远离它们。以俄罗斯为例。世界上领土最大的国家让德克萨斯人看起来像业余爱好者。确实如此。俄罗斯人在高大、耸立和庞大领域是真正的专家。而且不仅仅是从苏联过去开始的。
Europe's tallest skyscraper, 93 stories, is going up right now in Moscow, though they had to stop for a while on the 67th floor after it caught fire. Russia's southernmost city, Sochi, is the biggest construction site in Europe. That's because Sochi is hosting the Winter Olympics in 2014. So we headed down there to check it out. I went on a two hour bus ride from Sochi's center on the Black Sea up to the foothills of the Caucasus, where they're building the ski resorts.
欧洲最高的摩天大楼，93层，目前正在莫斯科建造，尽管他们在67层着火后不得不停工了一段时间。俄罗斯最南端的城市索契是欧洲最大的建筑工地。这是因为索契将举办2014年冬季奥运会。所以我们前往那里一探究竟。我从黑海边的索契市中心乘了两个小时的巴士，前往高加索山麓，他们正在那里建造滑雪胜地。
And maybe on that whole ride, there were a couple of five-minute stretches where I wasn't looking at a crane or a new hotel, or a bridge going up. They are moving to the beach. They are moving here. And they are starting to grow. I also met this man named Alexei Kravietz.
在那整个旅程中，也许只有几段五分钟的时间里，我没有看到起重机、新酒店或正在兴建的桥梁。他们正在向海滩推进。他们正在搬到这里。而且他们开始扩张。我还遇到了一个叫阿列克谢·克拉维茨的人。
He's lived all his life in a center block house by the Black Sea. The city wants to tear it down for a new rail yard. They've already demolished the rest of his neighborhood, but Kriviets has appealed his eviction in court. He says construction workers come up every day to scrape his walls with backhose, to scare him. We never asked the government for anything is what Kriviets is saying, and now the government
他一生都住在黑海边的一栋中心街区公寓里。市政府想拆掉它来建一个新的铁路调车场。他们已经拆毁了他社区的其他部分，但克拉维茨在法庭上对他的驱逐令提出了上诉。他说建筑工人每天都来，用挖掘机刮擦他的墙壁，以此恐吓他。克拉维茨说，我们从未向政府要求过任何东西，而现在政府
wants to take everything away from us. He's painted slogans and red paint on his windows, things like, people live here and SOS. Sometimes construction workers throw rocks through the windows. They fall in shards of Cyrillic all over the floor. Big crushing small. That story always seems to play itself out wherever there's a massive development. But there's a theory that big buildings don't just hurt little people.
想从我们这里夺走一切。他在窗户上用红漆写下了标语，比如“这里有人居住”和“SOS”。有时建筑工人会向窗户扔石头。西里尔字母的碎片散落在地板上。大鱼吃小鱼。无论哪里有大规模开发，这个故事似乎总是在上演。但有一种理论认为，大型建筑不仅伤害小人物。
They may in fact hurt the builders of those buildings too. There is the well-known fact in real estate that the great buildings tend to go up at the end of the cycle when everything is about to turn. That's a critic and philosopher Edward Tenor. While I was in Russia this last time, I found an essay online that he wrote in 2001. The Xanado effect. The Xanado effect is what I call the appearance of the big building, the big structure at the time when things are starting to go south. Tanner cites this idea known as the skyscraper curse, that tall buildings correlate with bad
它们实际上也可能伤害这些建筑的建造者。房地产界有一个众所周知的事实，即伟大的建筑往往在周期末端、一切即将发生转变时拔地而起。这是评论家和哲学家爱德华·泰纳的观点。当我在俄罗斯最后一次逗留时，我在网上发现了他2001年写的一篇文章。《世外桃源效应》。世外桃源效应是我对大型建筑、大型结构在事物开始走下坡路时出现的称呼。泰纳引用了这个被称为“摩天大楼诅咒”的观点，即高层建筑与糟糕的
times. So for instance, the Empire State Building was conceived in the 1920s, but not finished until the Great Depression. When it was known as the empty state building. The Sears Tower and the World Trade Center both opened in 1973 on the verge of another economic crisis. The people who run the NASDAQ exchange built the world's largest video display on time square in 1999, just a few months before the dot com bubble burst and the NASDAQ crashed. The Xanadu effect is a symptom of people overreaching, over planning, thinking that everything's going to go on
时期相关。例如，帝国大厦在20世纪20年代构思，但直到大萧条时期才完工。当时它被称为“空置大厦”。西尔斯大厦和世界贸易中心都在1973年、即另一场经济危机爆发前夕开业。纳斯达克交易所的人在1999年、即互联网泡沫破裂和纳斯达克崩盘前几个月，在时代广场建造了世界上最大的视频显示屏。世外桃源效应是人们过度扩张、过度规划的症状，认为一切都会
forever when it's about to turn the other way. I found Tenors theory a little comforting. Plus I think Olivia Newton-John's Zanadue is one of the biggest songs ever written. I see what you're trying to do there Julia and it's not going to work. No Olivia have you newton John, but Coleridge, I will allow. In Xanadu did Kubla Khan a stately pleasure dome decree. Actually, Tenor was thinking of the movie Citizen Kane and Kane's palace Xanadu. Okay then, Rosebud. It was a sledge. So, just as Citizen Kane built his palace while his empire crumbled, the big project can
永远持续下去，而实际上它即将转向反面。我发现泰纳的理论有点令人欣慰。另外，我认为奥莉维亚·纽顿-约翰的《世外桃源》是有史以来最伟大的歌曲之一。我明白你想做什么，朱莉娅，但这行不通。没有奥莉维亚·纽顿-约翰，但柯勒律治，我可以接受。在世外桃源，忽必烈汗下令建造了一座庄严的享乐宫殿。事实上，泰纳想到的是电影《公民凯恩》和凯恩的宫殿“世外桃源”。好吧，玫瑰花蕾。那是一辆雪橇。所以，正如公民凯恩在帝国崩溃时建造了他的宫殿一样，大型项目可以
be a big bad distraction. Tenor goes through several examples of the Zanadio effect in his original essay, but there are plenty of instances of big projects that don't presage any kind of crash. Tenor decides the example of Cass Gilbert's Woolworth building which went up in a boom time of 1913 and certainly didn't hurt the Woolworth Company. And it's hard to say where these gigantic state-driven projects like the Olympics fit into Xanity. Plus, there are plenty of critics who argue
成为一个巨大的糟糕干扰。泰纳在他的原始文章中列举了几个世外桃源效应的例子，但也有很多大型项目并没有预示任何形式的崩溃。泰纳引用了卡斯·吉尔伯特的伍尔沃斯大厦作为例子，它在1913年的繁荣时期建成，当然并没有伤害伍尔沃斯公司。而且很难说这些由国家驱动的巨大项目（如奥运会）如何符合世外桃源效应。此外，有很多评论家认为
that building height, much less bigness in general, cannot accurately predict a downturn at all. The bigness is a strategy that just about always fails, unless it succeeds. Or you can say it's one that that always succeeds except when it fails. And there's really no one way that you can regard it. You have to see it as a very powerful, easy to misuse, but also tempting way to go about things in life. So this energy effect might not provide the come-up ends that Julia desires, decides in any sort of downturn. The little person is still the one most likely to suffer. I guess the successor failure of Bigness really does depend on where you
建筑高度，更不用说整体的宏大，根本无法准确预测经济衰退。宏大是一种几乎总是失败的策略，除非它成功了。或者你可以说它是一种总是成功，除非它失败的策略。你真的无法用单一的方式来看待它。你必须把它看作是一种非常强大、容易被滥用，但也很有诱惑力的生活方式。所以这种能量效应可能无法提供朱莉娅所渴望的结局，在任何形式的衰退中，小人物仍然是最容易受苦的人。我想宏大的成功或失败确实取决于你
stand in relation to it. Are you on top of City Hall or down below? Big places just amplify our reactions. I went to a protest in Moscow where we marched down one of the city's wide Soviet Arab boulevards. Ordinarily I hate these boulevards because you can't actually cross them. You have to find a pedestrian tunnel and like sneak underneath. But for a few hours, Moscow's oppressive business became ours.
站在什么位置。你是在市政厅顶上还是在下面？大型场所只会放大我们的反应。我去莫斯科参加了一次抗议活动，我们沿着该市宽阔的苏联时代大道游行。通常我讨厌这些大道，因为你根本无法穿过它们。你必须找到一条人行隧道，像潜行一样穿过去。但有几个小时，莫斯科压抑的宏大变成了我们的。
The wide road, those stalin'erous skyscrapers and block long institutes, it all made us feel bigger too, though it was freezing. I love that despite the cold, people are smiling. Everybody is. That's my friend Vasili Sunkin. He grew up in Moscow, but he'd never experienced his grandiose city like this, as a grandiose stage for political expression.
宽阔的道路、那些斯大林式的摩天大楼和长达一个街区的机构，这一切也让我们感觉更宏大，尽管当时天气寒冷。我喜欢尽管天气寒冷，人们仍在微笑。每个人都在笑。那是我的朋友瓦西里·桑金。他在莫斯科长大，但他从未像这样体验过他那宏大的城市，作为政治表达的宏大舞台。
The way the crowds transform the national mall in Washington, D.C., or the Shams Ali's A in Paris. And even Edward Tenor says, that's what can be wonderful about thickness. It can elevate people, give them a sense of pride and purpose. I think a lot of the positive side of our cities are the big buildings when they're done well. New York without the Empire State Building, New York without the Chrysler Building, New York without Rockefeller Center would really be a poorer place. But I keep thinking about Alexei Kravjz and his standoff with developers in Sochi. Sometimes he goes out and films his confrontations with construction workers. I posted one of the films up on 99% of visible.org.
就像人群改变华盛顿特区的国家广场或巴黎的香榭丽舍大街那样。甚至爱德华·泰纳也说，这就是宏大可能带来的美妙之处。它可以提升人们，给他们一种自豪感和目标感。我认为我们城市积极的一面很多在于那些建造得很好的大型建筑。没有帝国大厦的纽约，没有克莱斯勒大厦的纽约，没有洛克菲勒中心的纽约，真的会是一个更贫乏的地方。但我一直在想阿列克谢·克拉维茨和他在索契与开发商的对峙。有时他会出去拍摄他与建筑工人的冲突。我把其中一段视频发布在了 99%invisible.org 上。
Everyone's speaking Russian, but it's not hard to understand what is going on. Kravyaetsa put some of his things in a metal storage unit behind his house. The workers showed up with a huge crane to haul it away. Kravyaetsa asked who they worked for, and the supervisor, this big burly guy, says, we are building the Olympic facilities. Then they hook up the crane while Kravyaets shouts at them. You can see a big building under construction behind them. That's a new train station, which will take in millions of visitors during the Olympic games. You can see the bones of what's going to be a soaring roof.
每个人都在说俄语，但不难理解发生了什么。克拉维茨把他的一些东西放在了他房子后面的一个金属储物单元里。工人们带着一台巨大的起重机出现，要把东西运走。克拉维茨问他们为谁工作，那个身材魁梧的监工说，我们正在建造奥运设施。然后他们钩住起重机，而克拉维茨对他们大喊大叫。你可以看到他们身后正在建造一座大型建筑。那是一个新的火车站，在奥运会期间将接待数百万游客。你可以看到那即将成为高耸屋顶的骨架。
A stately, pleasure dome. A stately, pleasure dome. Julia Barton traveled most recently to Russia for PRIs the world. You can find more of her stories by Julia Barton with a little help from me Roman Mars. It's a project of KALW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, in the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. Support for 99% Invisible is provided in part by tiny letters, email for people with something to say.
一座庄严的享乐宫殿。一座庄严的享乐宫殿。朱莉娅·巴顿最近前往俄罗斯为 PRI 的《世界》节目报道。你可以找到更多朱莉娅·巴顿的故事，并在我罗曼·马尔斯的帮助下了解更多。这是旧金山 KALW 91.7 本地公共广播电台和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。《99%隐形》的支持部分由 Tiny Letters 提供，这是为有话要说的人准备的电子邮件服务。
My boy Carver always says something to say. What do you have to say, Carver? Daddy long ago, it was two or three of eight minutes to fix that up to a tear and not spider. They are a raconids, but they are not spiders. That's a load off my mind. It's free, easy, minimal, powerful, the simplest way to write an email newsletter. Online at tinyletter.com.
我的男孩卡弗总是说有话要说。卡弗，你有什么要说的？爸爸，很久以前，有两三只八分钟的蜘蛛来修理那个，而不是蜘蛛。它们是蛛形纲动物，但它们不是蜘蛛。这让我松了一口气。它免费、简单、极简、强大，是撰写电子邮件通讯的最简单方式。在线访问 tinyletter.com。
This program is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public, more at prx.org. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars. You can always just catch up with us online at 99%invisible.org. Hello, it's Jason Heitz. or low. Thank you. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本节目由 PRX（公共广播交易所）分发，旨在让公共广播更加公开，更多信息请访问 prx.org。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞本节目。我在 Twitter 上是 @RomanMars。你也可以随时在 99%invisible.org 在线关注我们。你好，我是杰森·海茨。或者低。谢谢。你。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。